Oh ugly socks no more ugly socks why
doesn't my family love me oh wait
there's something else yes a new iPhone
cable seriously who doesn't need unfried
charging cables and more cloud storage
this year I say forget those fancy
iPhones and drones and give the digital
equivalent of socks totally boring tech
gifts that everyone will love number one
the gift of power anchor accessories
package together the following anchor
products an $11 power port elite 2 to
charge two gadgets simultaneously at
fast speed a $10 and up sturdy nylon
braided anchor power line plus cord to
replace those worn-out cables and
finally a $15.00 Power Core plus mini
battery to charge up when there's no
outlet nearby number two the gift of
security a password manager put $40 on a
Visa or Amex gift card give it to that
loved one who uses the same password
everywhere then make them purchase a
year-long subscription to - lien or one
password then explain how it works
number three the gift of connectivity
Netgear or be a mesh router seriously
the neck tear or B which starts at $300
is an awesome cure for those Wi-Fi dead
zones in your house the 2-pack comes
with a router and one satellite
whichever box is closest beams the
Internet to your device number four the
gift of storage iCloud and Google Drive
put fifty dollars on one of these iTunes
or App Store gift cards to help your
loved ones put an end to this 200
gigabytes of storage cost three dollars
a month for Android owners Google sells
Google Play cards
Google Drive starts at 100 gigabytes for
two dollars a month number five the gift
of cleanliness a microfiber cloth
get some good cloths like this $15 24
pack from Amazon okay there are a lot of
cloths but stuff them in the stockings
of all your dearest friends and family
so they can safely clean their gross
phones number six the gift of safety a
smartphone car mount I like best buys
$20 insignia vehicle mount even though
they use a photo of the first iPhone
slot your phone in here and then attach
it to the dashboard or the vent of your
car so your hands can stay on the wheel
wait that's it
what about a can of air or printer ink
for a mousepad more anti-virus software